this holy town in the Himalayas is
slowly sinking into the mountains
its homes crumbling
people desperate
now suddenly the authorities are asking
us to leave our house and they have not
provided us any assistance they have
just asked us to leave but we have
nowhere to go
we were making a house here we brought
bricks sand and reinforcing bars only
some days back one of my sons built a
new house but that is also of no use how
will we live here now
we spent everything on this house
[Music]
authorities are relocating people after
cracks appeared in homes
there have been reports that nearly 600
homes and hotels are sinking in the
North Indian town which has around 20
000 people
the major reasons for this are an
increased population an infrastructure
Boom the ntpc tunnel they're building
and the Blasting work being carried out
in the region because of this Joshi math
is sinking structures have developed
cracks and people are living in fear
joshymath is close to a number of
important religious sites in the
Himalayas attracting thousands of
pilgrims every year
the region is vulnerable to earthquakes
and has seen a number of disasters in
recent years experts blame melting
glaciers and Relentless Construction in
the area people here already live a
simple life losing their homes leaves
them with nowhere to go and no way to
make a living
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera